how did we get I pod how did they come
into being you can't really make a movie
on an entire underappreciated
understaffed underpaid R&D department in
a company so we're going to tell you the
story of the guy who employed him
because that's it's easier jobs so jobs
is a biographical picture of the life of
Steve Jobs innovator genius taskmaster
CEO whatever you want to call
him he's the guy who created Apple and
he was a big influence of all the cool
tech you love today release a lot of it
and Ashton Kutcher plays Steve Jobs I'm
not going to say he's like Leonardo
DiCaprio is Howard Hughes or Jim Carrey
is Andy Kaufman or Daniel day-lewis is
Lincoln I will say he was good as Steve
Jobs he had a lot of the Steve Jobs
mannerisms down you know that frumpy
walk that he always did Kutcher nailed
that when he's walking you're like
that's totally Steve Jobs so this
performance may be one small step and
the entirety of roles ever portrayed by
actors this is one giant leap for Ashton
Kutcher so he deserves props for this
other than that this is the life of
Steve Jobs the guy who made Apple so you
have some expectations there are things
you want to see in this movie because
you've heard so many stories I think I
want to see that I want to see that you
get it not really as a biographical
picture it's fine it's informative it's
a fictionalized portrayal of a guy's
life I love seeing leaders of industry
do their thing so when he's cracking
down and he's just coming up with these
ideas I love seeing it I'm like dude
that guy was crazy he asked the
impossible he expected the impossible
and they all went to work to create the
impossible that's really really cool to
see just saying I wanted the movie to
have a stronger script I'm probably
gonna compare this movie mentally to the
social network a lot well they're not
this fair I'm not sure I don't see why
it's unfair I was watching jobs and I
was like how much better with this movie
have been if it was written by Aaron
Sorkin the writer of this social network
in the newsroom you feel like Sorkin has
a really good way about having character
dialog completely make the movie and in
the movie like this that can be all the
difference in the world but in the end
you just kind of seeing Steve Jobs do
things with Apple and okay well he's
he's doing his thing example the dude
created a company there was a lot of
conflict in there you have Apple versus
Microsoft which let's face it that is a
war that's going on today Mac versus PC
is like the Nintendo versus Sega of the
modern age and that conflict is in the
movie what is the conflict it's one
phone call Ashton Kutcher Steve Jobs is
on the phone
and he's yelling at what I imagine is
Bill Gates's answering machine because
you don't actually see the dialogue it's
just him screaming in a phone and he
slams the phone down that's all you see
that conflict Steve Jobs feels like his
code was blatantly ripped off from him
the entire conflict one phone call that
sucks come on I want to see more of that
there's actually a little conflict in
the movie I'm not saying there's not
conflict I'm just saying you were never
at the edge of your seat going I hope he
gets through this the movie is a series
of situational circumstances that are
all lined up and Ashton Kutcher as Steve
Jobs is going through the movie until
the end of the movie and then the movies
done you're like okay I guess I was
informed now I feel like I could have
seen a two-hour biography on the History
Channel about Steve Jobs been just as
entertained possibly more entertained
because it's actually the facts it's all
real it's not fictionalized or anything
walked out of that had the same feeling
I will give jobs half props in the sense
that I was afraid that they were gonna
make Steve Jobs is this great guy and he
was never an although we have
all heard the stories about how the guy
was like hardcore like old-school James
Cameron and it does show that I
was glad they showed that way okay
they're not sugarcoating it they are
showing that this guy was so ambitious
that he came across as a dick sometimes
however they showed so much of that that
you're like all right was he just
unlikable I got to think it wasn't
totally like that so they swing so far
the other way I imagine to appease
people who were afraid that they were
gonna make him out to be this great guy
when he was an sometimes if they
just went full it's like okay
there's somewhere in the middle that
you're supposed to be in the end jobs
was interesting if you're interested in
tact like if you're an Apple fan and
you're a Steve Jobs fanatic you're gonna
want to watch jobs but I feel like a
great movie and even a really good movie
we have someone go into it who's really
uninterested in the subject and come out
going I am so interested in the subject
I am jumping on Wikipedia right now I'm
googling this situation and this person
I want to find out so much about him I
didn't really do that I felt like well
if you're an Apple fan and Steve Jobs
fan you're gonna like Jobs if you don't
care about either you're not gonna care
about this movie you walk out as
indifferent as you are when you walk in
so I can't say yeah you got to see jobs
right now I'll say it's a good time no
alcohol required if you're a Steve Jobs
fanatic otherwise Jobs is a good time if
you're drunk yeah
a party so innovators who is your
favorite innovator of all time we're
talking all time if you know the name of
the person who painted the first cave
paintings name that person we're talking
innovators of all time whoever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]